[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to features
cat class this in this video will like
to finish up what we have left for the
diamond model and we already finished
last time for the tap apart and today
we're going to finish the bottom part so
let's take a look on what are two part
for the bottom I'm going to turn into
the ghost view and you can see right
here there are two main part for the
bottom which you have the lower half
facet and in fact it is actually go if
you go
trace these faces to the top it is
divided by eight section as well
the other one is pavilion man pheasant
and again everything goes by eight right
so we are going to follow this rule
let's get started this is what we have
left from last video for the top part
I'm going to turn on the finish one and
to talk about the next step if you look
at the top view you're going to see
already put here for their eight points
here one two three four five six feet
alright and what they are from the left
view is actually where does face facet
meet right there and we are going to
draw a polygon on a top view as a
guideline so I'm going to draw octagons
stepping into the zero and just kind of
eyeball it to fall about close to that
point
okay and then I want to bring this point
down oh sorry I need to go back to this
view so you you understand motion where
is that okay and then I want to bring
this down to approximately where they
are going to be all right so you're
going to see this a octagon over there
and next what we need to do is simply
just link well you know does a curve
together straight line together before
we do that we also need to create a
thickness for a girdle
so I'm going to pick up the curve that I
have and I'm just going to simple bring
down my gum ball and hit the Alt key to
make a copy and next you just need to
link I want to link the line from this
is a line to the endpoint and click on
the endpoint and snapping into one of
the corner for the octagon
same thing here same thing here and I go
into the link to the this one day so you
got a big triangle there next one we're
going to link this one to the next
corner and the same thing this one going
down and to link to the second point I
kind of fast for war and change the
color of this or you will see the reason
line festival is they are the same thing
you only need to do one part and then we
walk doing the polar array but I just
want to show you the structure I think
it's easier for you to understand this
way okay so we have all eight now with
the big triangle right there
constructing by this line and this line
we need to have eight section there so
I'm just going to go ahead
to eight at eight section like this and
I just going to continue in to finish Oh
a of them okay so this is a curved line
we have and I kind of turn it into a red
color so you can see the next step is
exactly the same like last step which
use surface from two three four inches
all right so I pick up the HS and that
will creating a surface and one more
time now we finish the eight surface I
kind of fast forward a little bit so you
see all those eight faces right there
now we need to do the final one is the
Pavillion men face faces we need to find
out where the culet is going to be and
the best way that I find is to put a dot
a point by the center okay and then we
want to move that point down to be our
killer point but we need to know exactly
where it is because we want to have our
faces really straight you can try become
loyal higher you're going to notice this
faces may not be completely straight so
to find out to be completely straight
this is what I do I go to the front view
okay and I'm going to extend it this
curve out and pass the center and then
so I can bring my point back to snap it
into the center so that will be where
the culet is going to be so I kind of
throw a curve a snap to end point all
right before I move it how do I know
what angle is correct I'm going to tap
on the tap T PAB and you kind of see it
as a white line coming out and then I
choose this edges so if I move my mouse
we will follow the ages that we have
because I hit the tab key and I'm going
to continue pass it so now this line is
actually is an extension of the very H
line then I'm going to move my point and
holding the shift and you see int
intersection is on so that will be a
point for our culet now let's go back to
the perspective so all we need to do we
no longer need this guy there right and
I'm going to link from the end point -
my point at the qulet endpoint to the
toilet again and next we just need to
create a surface again the surface from
two three four edges so edge one two
three and four so now we have this facet
thing all we need to do is we're going
to pick up all nine faces fascist here
here here and one more nine you this one
okay and then we're going to go to the
top view then we're going to do the
polar array here on the zero the number
of item mixture is eight 360 degrees
here we go we have professor only thing
is missing now is the girl okay so I'm
going to draw a curve I would say curve
because vehicle they are curved whether
they are straight all the actually
curves curve so I'm going to link let me
look at a perspective view you can think
about anywhere you just need to make
sure that they are aligned okay I'm
gonna pick up here
so create this little profile there okay
since I break down all the curve on the
girdle so I'm just gonna go ahead and
select them and then I'm going to join
them okay so we're going to do sweet -
so this is your real one
first curve if your rail rail - is right
there and this why we just draw it well
be your cross-section so now we have our
stone all we need to do is join it
together all right so now we have a lot
of round stone there - making it to the
Oval whoops now you have a Olaf stone
that's easy once you've done the first
one the second one is easier alright so
this is our stone demonstration I hope
you enjoyed and I will see you soon in
my other video
[Music]